et aujourd'hui je vais vous raconter les
émissions pour enfants dans ma barre
alors installez-vous au coin du feu à
regarder vivais mes paroles bien entendu
et je rappelle que l'abus d'alcool est
dangereux pour la santé
nous sommes le 10 décembre 1962 petite
révolution les enfants ont droit à un
programme entièrement dédié aux enfants
c'est bien sûr bonne nuit les petits
vous rappeler ce module est petit c'est
tous les soirs à 19h 20 sur la première
chaîne qui s'appelait avant l'ol de
lower tf parce qu'avant c'était le rts
et évidemment on ne se lasse pas du
générique puisque même les poux jeunes
même moi voilà j'ai pas connu bonne nuit
les petits
mais c'était il y avait une première
version en noir et blanc et vous allez
voir le générique quoi qu'il arrive que
vous ayez voilà quinze ans que vous ayez
202 ans eh bien regardez il vous parle
isabelle si tu nous regardes machine
isabelle monin bas à sochi et te parle
parce qu'en 1962 il a tu avais déjà 60 2
e bro soir écouter patron les enfants
qui chantent
je descends sans faire de bruit mon
échelle sur ma petite maman
embrasser bien fort la vôtre de maman
elle votre papa aussi nous
alors gastrique os qui je disais je
regardais et en 74 alors ça c'était la
première émission pour enfants 74 il ya
une île pas comme les autres qui
apparaît à la 10 shekels il valait river
daynile aux sofica tu t'appelles valérie
bénaïm merci je ne crois que je crois
pas que mojo hand ball escape une île
pas comme les autres l'île aux enfants
et le mythique monstres gentils casimir
voici venu le temps maintenant oui car
j'ai regardé casimir et casimir que
j'adore moi et en plus ils allaient à la
même cabine à uv que bernard montiel
regard
[Musique]
je suis en train de me préparer un
gloubi boulga qui a d'abord dû chocolat
en poudre à chocolat en poudre et de la
confiture de fraises considère de
fraises j'adore ça de la banane écrasée
dans avait écrasé ce travail c'est très
bien avec de la moutarde de la mouture
wii et de la saucisse de toulouse c'est
willy les enfants casimir on voit là je
sais pas qui regardais mes séries qui
étaient ils tous casimir c'est quand je
vois c'est le casimir tunisien s'est
résumée benchetrit urbaine cepici aller
n'était plus c'est la révolution il ya
33 ans en 87 apparaît le cultissime club
dorothée sur tf1 avec jacky ariane
corbier patrick simpson jones eric
galliano
ils font le choix entre chaque dessin
animé et sitcoms voilà qui sont
diffusées regardez le générique et après
on va voir ensuite qu'ils se marient
bien en plateau à l'extérieur c'est vrai
que là je sais que vous allez kiffer
club dorothée c'est toujours un carton
regard des génériques
tintin tintin
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est vous les commerçants franchement
elle est ronde à nous je vais pas garder
de toi c'est moi la vedette
[Rires]
mais williams et ariane voilà qui nous a
quittés c'est vrai que donc le club
dorothée c'était un énorme carton ça a
été pendant des années à la télévision
et c'était bien sûr jean luc azoulay le
génie un voile hacker qui s'occupait qui
était producteur de cette émission
qu'est ce qui s'est passé sur le club
dorothée
pourquoi ça s'est arrêté benjamin
castaldi pourquoi je sais a été bien je
crois parce que tf1 avait assez de faire
la fortune
désolé de berba ça coûte et ça c'était
des heures et 17 heures de programmes
par jour je crois je crois il semble non
monsieur je prends mais c'est pas sûr
une bonne raison là vous dix des douze
jours
la note je sais je sais mais je pense
que je vais y avait de ça je peux me
tromper mais je crois que c'est un peu
là c'est le retour du forcené qui disent
qu'on aime beaucoup jean michel mr ben
quoi comment ça il fait ressortir de
quelqu'un qui enrichit la chaîne ça ccc
c'est tout le monde est content tournée
gagnant c'est gagnant gagnant dans sa
pâte sans son sac noir et et c'est pas
possible
non et c'est parce qu'il avait beaucoup
de députés truc qui qui qui vraiment qui
voilà qui essayait de de mettre des
bâtons dans les roues cette émission qui
était destiné aux enfants et une fumée
en plus il ya des abrutis qui sont dits
oui c'est pas une émission
voilà qui donne un bon exemple aux
enfants alors que pas du tout c'est
forcément derrière c'est vrai que voilà
ça c'était un peu plus compliqué oui
valérie vous êtes passés au civil en
fait c'est que il ya eu l'arrivée dans
cette émission des mangas pour la
première fois les mangas que les députés
il ya eu un débat carrément à
l'assemblée nationale mener le front
était menée par ségolène royal et elle
estimait que ses dessins animés qui
était beaucoup trop violent pour la
jeunesse française et qu'il fallait
arrêter c'est donc la nouvelle micra
devenir ça fait ça fait déjà plus de 40
ans que ségolène royal dit des conneries
alors ça en fait
ce qu'il faut retenir de ce bolide
ségolène royal en tout cas on embrasse
son cousin couscous il est bien plus un
pas qu'elle en 1989 il ya jean pierre
foucault autre ami jean pierre qui prend
en main les dimanches après midi tf1
avec disney parade il y avait anne avec
lui je me rappelle très amoureux de hann
rions pas l'étaler que lui elle
présentait avec jean pierre foucault
regardez c'est notre jean pierre dans
disney parade pas bonjour voici disney
parade
comme chaque dimanche après midi toute
la famille est installée devant le
téléviseur
je vous propose un spectacle de grande
qualité le monde merveilleux de walt
disney la boxe est alors excusez moi
mais tout est tombé dans le jardin j'ai
dû tout ramasser bah oui je sais bien
c'est ce que tu m'as dit au téléphone
mais est-ce que tu seras pas du tout à
l'heure pour répondre à tout le courrier
alors reprends ton souffle le temps pour
nous de regarder peut-être un premier
dessin animé tu veux bien d'accord allez
on commence à s'occuper du courrier puis
on se retrouve dans quelques instants
que se passe-t-il au restaurant quand on
décide comme donald de ne pas payer la
note a surtout quand la somme demandée
faramineuses eh bien on est condamné à
faire la vaisselle
ouais et alors il paraît que ségolène
royal avait fait je vous dis à l'époque
ségolène royal qui s'était plainte à
l'assemblée c'est une jeune députée elle
s'était plainte du gilet de jean pierre
foucault dans les faits ségolène royal
voilà a connu plus d'échecs que de
victoire 7 6 je vais faire le livre la
stratégie de l'échec est toujours torah
que oui j'aime pas balancer les deux
habitent une galaxie amour et l'époque
de hann
je peux vous dire aujourd'hui que
c'était réciproque c'était réciproque
qui va faire une bonne intervention
cette émission je vous pose avec 193 en
93 y avait des personnalités de l'époque
qui se transformer en marionnettes sur
france 3 il ya eu l'apparition des mini
comme pour apple c'est arrivé en 93 ces
deux retours actuellement 1 sur france 4
est ce qu'avec génial c'était leur
générique regardez
[Musique]
nous sommes les mini comme se surnomment
sa com
comme moi pas mesnil comme je suis mag
c'est coco jojojura de mener sur youtube
voici du vent comme en famille
on a soirée
c
contrairement au climat une chanson
[Musique]
on essaie on
il est urgent fait ça mais je regardais
mes limites poussins benjamins minimes
et déjà répondre et leur j'ai même pas
envie non parisse mau 93 ans via une
émission
voilà qui était fait pour les ouvres
sais c'est pas sorcier présenté par fred
est jeune je me rappelle et jamy après
qui a tourné un james bond payant jamie
plus j'avance fait cette émission
c'était les maquettes qui servait à
sousse expliqué les mecs t'expliquer
n'importe quoi regarder
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pompéi et russes et amphithéâtres et la
fiom une moissonneuse batteuse lost
signé david hicks mesdames et messieurs
les coulisses de l'opéra garnier avec
ses décors suspendu et toute la
machinerie approche me mets pas ton
doigt dedans en ballon tu exagères j'en
ai partout où ce parti dont jamie
[Musique]
séquelles et gazeuse
voilà donc c'est pas sorti bon en vrai
ça je vais m'entraîner je m'en fout en
fait je suis comment raconter l'histoire
les enfants sans parler des teletubbies
voilà on adoré de béquilles deep sea
life ils vivent à teletubbies landes
voilà alors que jean michel mr
viatelecom landes et c'est dans un bon
état et il faisait un peu n'importe quoi
ils se nourrissent de tout pathos et de
t'choupi deluxe alors franchement moi je
suis fou des teletubbies je suis paumé
en fait parce que je me posais une
question je suis sûr que vous si je vous
disais comment ça ça peut faire un tel
carton j'arrivais partiront en fait
valérie benaïm on va revoir à l'excès et
vous allez avoir votre théorie puisque
valérie bénaïm elle travaille également
dans les délais tajine
c'est l'homme c'est le
la télécabine c'est l'heure des
teletubbies
[Musique]
la bobine la vie jours voilà les séries
et voilà bah ça ça fait des cartons je
peux vous dire que le mec qui sait bien
il en a pris de losail est à mon avis le
mec quand il avait créé ça franchement
il avait fumé aux gars ils étaient
défoncés à lui je n'y crois pas un mec
il a fait fortune avec cette connerie